have you ever wondered what happens when
you click run in Android studio the
Gradle build tool swings into action
fetching dependencies compiling code and
packaging resources experts at Gradle
and Udacity have teamed up to create
Gradle for Android and Java a course
designed to help everyday developers and
experts alike demystified Gradle and
what it can do for you and your apps in
this course you'll learn the Gradle
build language create and integrate
libraries write tests and create an app
with free and paid versions Gradle is a
key tool in the Android developers tool
belt and once you learn the ins and outs
you'll wonder how you ever got by
without it get started now your users
are waiting for more information visit
udacity.com/google
you